[Music]
another installments night in our series
drug to the opioid epidemic is the worst
drug crisis in the history of this
country every year drug overdoses kill
more people in the entire Vietnam War
and the vast majority of those are
caused by opioids as you well know by
now but in a twist on past drug
epidemics opioid abuse is directly
caused by American medicine huge
quantities of opioid painkillers are
prescribed every year and that has
created millions of addicts not everyone
is convinced though that painkillers are
to blame dr. Steve stenoses president of
the American Academy of pain medicine
and he joins us tonight dr. thanks for
coming on I appreciate it thanks for
having me Tucker thanks so I at the kind
of the very nascent stages of the
current disaster this epidemic your
organization along with another released
this statement and I just want to get
your take on it now
21 years later and I'm quoting studies
indicate that the development of
addiction when opioids are used for the
relief of pain is low furthermore
experience has shown that known addicts
can benefit from the carefully
supervised judicious use of opioids in
light of everything we've seen in the
past 21 years what do you think of that
statement well I think we've learned a
lot over the last twenty years around
pain management going back to that
statement it was stated that the risk
for addiction was low I think over time
we've seen that there is a risk for
addiction with patients and it's still a
problem but the using medications with
the wrong patients that develop an
addiction problem are misusing the
medicines can lead to all sorts of
problems but the studies more recently
have shown that the the risk of
addiction from starting with pain
separate from having a substance abuse
problem is from at least 10 percent or a
little higher than that so it's low but
it's still significant so we really need
to be careful and who gets these
medicines and deciding if these are
effective therapies I think what's one
important Tucker is that really pain
management isn't synonymous with opioid
management you know there's options to
patients if you take three steps back
here you have physicians who I think are
almost universally trusted by people or
trained to trust them their job is to
heal us right
basically telling people to take more
opioids and now we have tens of
thousands of dead and whole communities
destroyed in the middle class life
expectancy literally shrinking because
of this and it's like oh sorry we are
wrong
wouldn't a more functional society
punish people who said something like
that well I think the the focus
obviously be on how do we assess who's
effective for this treatment what types
of treatments could they benefit from
like I explained there's so many other
options for patients and maybe a small
percentage of patients need to be on
opioids as part of the treatment plan
but I'm not sure about accusing who was
wrong or right I'm saying this so I mean
there are all kinds of mistakes that
people make and you know most of them
are in good faith but if the industry
that makes the product he's using
physicians to convince other physicians
and then the public to use more of the
product then I think it's fair to
suspect there's a financial motivation
and I don't want to be a lefty about it
but I don't want to use the phrase greed
is killing people but it kind of looks
like that a little bit if you see what I
mean again I can't speak for what a
pharmaceutical company might do I would
hope they would work in in the interest
of the patient but again I really think
the the discussion should be on how do
we assess patients for pain management
and understand that we have these other
treatments for those patients and if
they do it develop an addiction problem
what are the resources for those
patients so I think really we need to
expand our understanding of pain
management in you know kind of deal with
the the patients are suffering and we
have significant millions of patients
with chronic pain and they need to have
their pain treated effectively of course
I'm not implying that that they all need
to be on opioids and there's been a lot
done to kind of decide and do a better
job of stratifying patients deciding you
know which patients are at risk which
patients aren't how do we monitor
patients better I think those are the
that's where the medicine is going and
hopefully from that that's going to help
at least from the prescription side you
know see a reduction the deaths related
to opioid prescriptions but hold on I
wonder what you thought over the past 15
years or what the manufacturers thought
when they saw of course they know where
their product goes so they did see it
that there were counties in West
Virginia and
tucky that we're getting by a factor of
let's say 10 more opioid doses and they
had people wildly disproportionate to
any conventional human need clearly
that's feeding a raging addiction of
social disaster and they didn't do
anything about it where were you and
that was happening but I mean I I can't
say for what was done in these smaller
communities well I have to say that
there was in some cases diversion of
medicines there were pill mills where
physicians or bad apples were you know
prescribing knowingly that these
medicines were going to be abused and
misused I can't support that I don't
think any physician but where were the
manufacturers no but but all and it was
your group that helped convince
physicians to be looser in their
prescription of opioids and of course
the manufacturers are getting the
Sackler family has gotten extremely rich
on the Forbes list because of it they
knew this was happening but they didn't
do anything and I don't understand why
well I think I would I would may be
correct that is that the art group the
American had a pain meds and other pain
associations and physician groups the
American Medical Association have been
supporting you know appropriate
management of chronic pain and again
whether that includes opioids or not so
our goal has always been to assess
patients there's a number of different
strategies the physicians can use to you
know help monitor patients to see if
they're taking their medicines
effectively I get it but if you're
suggesting that people use opioids in
ways that they didn't before and that's
what the statement we read suggests
isn't it incumbent upon you to see how
that turns out
so you see like you know massive amounts
of hydrocodone or going to some pharmacy
in Florida or Wheeling West Virginia
don't you get on the phone with the
federal government and say whoa whoa
whoa no there's something wrong here
but no one did that yeah it's okay I'm
not sure what happened at the federal
level at the state level to you know to
kind of a deal what won't be more aware
of this criminal activity that was going
on around that again our focus was
really and has been to really push for a
better treatment of chronic pain okay
doctor thank you for joining us I
appreciate it